Greetings everybody, my name is Sam Dider and I'm a senior Unreal Engine instructor with Epic Games.
In the following video tutorial, we're going to be taking an introductionary look at Niagara
and how we can use Niagara to power all sorts of visual effects inside of Unreal.
Now, we're first going to start off by exploring what Niagara is.
Then we're going to take a look at the Niagara content examples as these provide a really great reference
for all of your questions that you might have about Niagara when it comes to what it can do
and even help give you ideas of things that you might not have considered before.
Then we're going to take a look at the Niagara Editor overview
and we're going to punish that up with creating our first Niagara effect.
That's right, we're going to be actually getting hands on with this and creating a smoke using Niagara.
So, let's go ahead and jump right in with what is Niagara.